hoosh Sherlock Holmes a game of shadows
alright so if you remember my review of
Sherlock Holmes which was an early
review of mine like back in the day my
video reviewing career I didn't like
Sherlock Holmes that much and I saw it
again not too long ago I was like yet I
still just kind of find nothing the
movie so now we got Sherlock Holmes to
and I was like alright you know maybe
it'll step it up it has Moriarty and I
love Moriarty I love the guy playing him
- he's that guy from Fringe is all like
Olivia Dunham plays I like him alright
so when Sherlock Holmes - is pretty much
what you need to know about a Sherlock
Holmes and Watson are back and now
they're battling professor James
Moriarty who's like Sherlock Holmes is
equal and his Sherlock Holmes - better
than one yeah it actually is a lot for
the first part of this movie I was like
alright it kind of feels like Sherlock
Holmes one you know I'm following it but
whatever and then the Moriarty stuff
kicks on you're like this guy literally
makes the movie he does have help though
I mean Robert Downey jr. is Sherlock
Holmes and Jude Law's Watson they're
perfect I love them in the first one
they still have the same chemistry and
this one that you love from the first
one and they're just their prime now
Robert Downey jr. he's just a good actor
the guy's method actor - he is the
character I've heard some gripes about
his British accent but I'm American so
it all sounds like Australian to me but
the dude locks himself into this role
and he's great at it and you'd love what
I like about Jude Law's Watson Watson is
relevant he's not as smart as Sherlock
Holmes but he's still really smart at
what he does he's a relevant character
in this movie and I love that now that
got professor James Moriarty alright
this guy is awesome you don't have the
generic villain that Mark Strong was in
the first one I always think mark Strong
is just kind of a generic villain like
he was a villain in a movie and people
are like yeah him and villain in a movie
forever James Moriarty is so smart and
so is Sherlock Holmes and is great
seeing these two intellectual superiors
just going at each other
what I wanted in this movie is what I
got in this movie they even have those
moments where they actually talk to each
other all civil like you know it's not
like oh you're the hero and I'm the
villain we must duel now like now we can
talk and have a conversation in a room
and we'll just try to one-up each other
so even their conversations are battles
that's right you don't have any of the
exploding slow-motion trees none of the
bullets whizzing by and none of the
slow-mo arms snapping or anything like
that but still the dialogue between
James Moriarty and Sherlock Holmes a
battle in and of its
self and they're probably my favorite
battles in the movie now one of the
things I didn't like about the first
movies alright Sherlock Holmes is really
smart he is smarter than anyone he sees
everything and they illustrate that in
this movie this one girl was like what
are you seeing he's like everything
that's my curse he walks into a room he
knows where everything is how he catches
the clues he catches in the first movie
they do that but you're not there with
him because they didn't tell you what he
saw and apparently I wasn't the only one
who hated that because in this movie
they fixed that he tells you now what he
saw not like every moment Reese finest
stuff but after every scene he's like oh
yeah there was this and there was this
no you did this and there was this and
then you thought I missed this but
there's actually this this is where
we're going so it's a little more on
board with it this time around made me
feel all smart and [ __ ] so it had great
stylized fun action great acting great
characters a great villain doing battle
with a great hero or inspector in the
end I will say this movie is a good time
no alcoholic wired the movies not
amazingly special but it's fun I like
seeing smart people throw down with
smart people it's just my thing I guess
so even if you didn't like the first one
you might still like this one I didn't
like the first one I like this one there
you go
so who's your favorite smart person hero
or villain you know the dude you're like
the guy is just too smart he's all
Victor Von Doom and [ __ ] you can still
use Victor Von Doom even though I use
Victor Von Doom here not saying Victor
Von Doom is mine I don't know Greg house
he's great yeah
house homes house is based off Sherlock
Holmes it works for me comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more ohh
you